now question of the day is how many
bodies is too many bodies for a girl for
a girl as long as there's lower than
mine we're good three ten i think when
you're hitting double digits like 10 10
or over i think that's a lot yeah if
you if you're on the triples yeah then
yeah that's mad if you're in the triples
all right so so girl has she's a 10 but
she slept with 20 people what is she
back
what's a two bag
twenty twenty two it's about oh she's in
it okay well how okay let's say let's
say thirty thirty just calm
what's your body count free zero you're
a virgin yeah okay ah come on love be
serious yeah you can't tell me no not on
youtube they're like over under 50.
under 50 over under 20. can't confirm
with the nada we're going to be
interviewing girls today do you think
they'll tell me no no no no
no i'll do that what's your body code
this i'm saving myself my husband okay
call me you are you virgin let's just
say it's on the 20. okay next question
rate yourself one to ten get myself an
ico eleven twenty uh seven on a good day
maybe at eight point five okay so if you
can't use seven you give yourself an
eight maybe it's maybe not seven seven
solid seven is sleeping around different
for men and for women actually i don't
believe in a double standard but i see
if you're single do it but you still
look down upon aren't you i think it's
different for women because we carry
more of an emotional attachment to it
whereas men they just do it for the sake
of doing it
okay sit like this here when you're a
woman someone's putting it inside you in
it so so that's unit like that's that's
your sort of space but when it's someone
else it's a man they're just going in
and out they're going to the next one
you know what i mean so it's like for
goals it's more man it's like do you
know what i'm saying i agree yeah yeah
so if there were ever such thing as too
many bodies for a guy that you would
date me that like so if you're
interested in a guy and he says i've
slept with this many people i don't ask
the question because i feel like what
you've done you've done so so you don't
it doesn't matter i don't ask the
question and i don't expect you to trust
me the damn question needs to me that's
the past so i wouldn't let it affect the
future so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. what do you
think the average body count is for a 31
year old woman in the in in today yeah
i would say
i'm going off what the people that i
know i've heard i'd probably say like 20
20 25 i'd say about 18 80.
i was like who do you know
would you rather take a girl with 50k in
in debt and credit card debt or 50
bodies
the what you wife you wife a girl with
50 bodies or with 50k in credit card
debt and if i'm up i'm doing the the
debt if no because this is a nice goal
you help each other out the one in debt
100 okay so you take 50k in debt over
50. she's a good goal she's a good goal
100 i actually feel so awkward asking
people their body counts
like i feel like
oh my god i get so nervous sleeping
around different for men and for women
yes or no yeah men don't have to face
the consequences yeah i think the same i
think yeah when when women do it it's
not really acceptable that when guys do
it it's fine i don't know oh for sure
definitely it depends less fun though
it's not less fun it's just that women
face how to face the consequences men
like just get branded as like legends
and women judge other women as well for
sleeping around i think but as as you
get older at the moment yeah i think
people care less nowadays if girls sleep
around more younger in school that's
when it's like
some dudes especially with like the
whole andrew tate thing some dudes
actually care about body count and [ __ ]
that's so true do you think body count
matters [ __ ] no in fact the higher the
better you actually know what you're
doing in bed so i have a question would
you guys say your body count no so if it
doesn't matter like why don't people
just say it i don't know what's your
buddy
dude i'm saying my friends
but it's just it's just interesting
because we'll say it doesn't matter but
then it's like if it doesn't matter why
doesn't everyone just say it very
intellectual thoughts because honestly
like for a guy for a guy i think i think
like like personally like i wish i was a
virgin i wish i would wait until
marriage i think one is too many
i wish i did yeah i really i like i wish
i was a virgin yeah really you have a
relationship and you need to know that
the person that you're going to marry is
yeah exactly i figured that sexual
chemistry sexual chemistry is so
important so i i feel like if you wait
you won't know like okay i think it's
different like once you've had sex when
men are allowed to have fun and women
con until marriage
i mean i think it's it's actually if you
look at the stats it's better if they're
both virgins like the longest marriages
are if both people compare it to i guess
if it's your first time you everything
feels great
i don't know
she doesn't know do you know what i mean
those but it's it's just interesting
because like when i ask people they say
it doesn't matter but then no one ever
wants guys to eat too they don't want to
say it either yeah that's what's really
saying yeah yeah my guy friends are like
i'd rather not tell you my body count
just
it's like it's just personal information
isn't it
what are you so the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. what do you
think the average body count is for a 31
year old woman 40 40.
50 maybe
20 31 oh my god i didn't well 20 23. we
went high
do you know what's interesting though i
asked guys how many bodies there's too
many bodies they all say 10.
but but that's what i'm saying but
everyone i ask what's the average body
count of first marriage it's above 10 so
it's like it seems like someone's
capping yeah they're not being realistic
for females there's a lot more body
count than males i think you're you're
right one out of three men are either
virgins or they haven't had sex in the
past year so that's that's the thing
like the reason girls say men are trash
and like you guys have this perception
that men are sleeping around like not
you but like like
in general but it's because like we're
all sleeping with the same guys because
it's only five percent of men get
matches really on tinder that's mad yeah
so if you if you hook up with a guy off
an online like you're one of like
sleeping around is it different for men
and for women yeah why because there's
like a stereotype in it that obviously
women should be not sleeping around and
mention
but i mean women should because at the
end of the day if you're single why not
or is it the same spirit should be the
same what do you think i think it used
to be but not anymore would you be cool
with the girl that slept with 500 men
that's her own business you can do what
she wants no i'm saying would you would
you marry her i mean if she's good to me
either he wouldn't i probably wouldn't
but i don't think i wouldn't expect
loads of girls to marry me if i did do
you feel like it's the same in society
it's treated equally no not through
everyone yeah do you think body count
matters no
what's your body count
three right
that's funny that's what we said people
would say tonight
before we came out i haven't got a high
body camp but it shouldn't matter but
you know what i mean it's just
interesting because everyone says it
doesn't matter but a lot of times people
don't want to say it
[Music]
is sleeping around different for men and
for women yes or no is sleep is sleeping
around different for men and for
why
because guys when they can get away with
anything and us scales get labelled i
mean it can be the same you know we are
men so it can't be the same it can't be
the same cannot you cannot why because
men have the intensity
we feel the intensity of the of the
movement of the the music
deep down
what do you think what do you think for
me it's the same sleeping around
different for men and for women yeah why
because not only the same [ __ ] bro
men are supposed to stay loyal but it's
just when we when we go around it
doesn't mean anything when girls do it
it does mean something is that do you
think that's fair it's not fair at all
we're going to live our lives do you
think body count matters if you're
dating a guy do you care what his body
counts i don't [ __ ] cannot ask a
question will you will you tell him if
he asks you a lie
how many how many bodies there's too
many bodies for you to wife a girl 10 10
10 no okay chill bro 15 15 50 20 50
because
because the girls here are different
yeah yeah that's better
i'm from america i don't know what it is
a london woman not special we love him